20-19 has been an important year for the
way developers handle online payments in
September banks in the EU started
rolling out strong customer
authentication this means that if you
have customers in the EU they may need
to log into their bank's website to
authorize a payment before it can be
processed in today's video we'll look at
two different strategies you can use
with stripe to accept payments in your
app both of which are fully compatible
with this 3d secure process if you're
new here like and subscribe and check
out the stripe payments master course
for everything you need to know about
building a payment system in today's
video we'll be looking at how to handle
one-time payments the easy way to get
paid is with stripe checkout it can be
implemented with Xero back-end code but
has limited options for customization
when we're done with that we'll look at
a more complex approach that combines
stripe elements with the payment intents
API and that will give us full control
over the payment flow and user
experience to get started you'll need to
have a stripe account and then you'll
also want some kind of nodejs back-end
will be using firebase cloud functions
for this video but feel free to use any
node back-end that you want in the
front-end application we just have a
single product and that is the only
product that the user can buy when they
click the purchase button it will bring
up the stripe checkout UI this is a
checkout flow that is completely handled
by stripe that means you don't have to
handle any of the UI coding yourself
stripe will validate the credit card and
process the payment all inside of this
checkout page and it also handles the 3d
secure authentication process for
customers in Europe if the user does not
complete this process by signing into
their own bank and authorizing the
charge the payment will not go through
when the payment is complete you can
specify a redirect URL and stripe will
redirect the user to a success page
along with the ID of the session so you
can retrieve it if necessary and if the
payment is unsuccessful or if the user
cancels you can go to a separate URL
once you've received a payment from a
user you then need to think about how
you'll actually fulfill their purchase
and this is entirely dependent on how
your business operates one option is to
just go into the stripe dashboard and do
all that stuff manually but we're
developers so we want to do everything
programmatically and the way you do that
with striped checkout is with a web hook
when the checkout process has been
completed successfully stripe can send a
web hook with some data to your back-end
server so that means that you need to
have a server that's accessible over
HTTP
which is very easy to do and a perfect
use case for firebase cloud functions
when your cloud function receives the
webhook it will contain data about the
payment intent and you can use that data
to implement some logic that updates
your database or maybe sends an email to
the user or something along those lines
what's amazing about stripe check out is
that we can build a payment system
without writing a single line of
back-end code to get started you'll
first need a stripe account head over to
the stripe dashboard and then make sure
to flip the switch for development mode
under API keys you'll see a publishable
key this key is perfectly safe to use in
your front-end code however you should
never use the secret key in your
front-end code we'll come back here to
retrieve the secret key when we set up
our web hook on firebase cloud functions
now at this point you should know that
there are two different ways you can use
stripe check out the easiest approach is
to use the client only integration to
use this approach we need to go into the
products tab and create some details
about a product that we want to sell one
of the big limitations with this
approach is that we can't calculate our
pricing dynamically all the data is
static based on the values that we enter
here in the dashboard if you have
dynamic pricing or maybe you offer
discounts on a per user basis you'll
likely want to generate your checkout
sessions on a server that allows you to
generate products and their pricing
based on your own internal logic so
you're not dependent on the products
here in the dashboard we look at how to
do that in the full course but for this
simple use case we'll just stick with
the client only integration after you've
created a product go ahead and add a SKU
to it and then copy that SKU ID from
there we'll go ahead and open up a
terminal session and use npx to create a
new svelte app then inside the source
directory I'll create a component called
product spell now in order to run the
checkout process we need to include
stripe J s in this project instead of
installing stripe with NPM we want to
include a script tag in the head of the
document so head into the public folder
to the index.html and add stripe J s
there this ensures that you always have
the latest version of stripe J s and
also allows stripe to perform things
like fraud detection in the background
from there we can go into our product
components and the first thing we'll
want to do is initialize the stripe SDK
by including the script tag we get a
global namespace of stripe which we can
initialize by passing it the publishable
key from the stripe dashboard and that
is how stripe identifies our account
next we'll declare a few props for the
product name image and SKU now if we
want to redirect the user to the
checkout process all we have to do is
set up an async function and then we'll
wait stripe redirect to checkout you can
add multiple items to the checkout
process and set a quantity for each one
then you'll want to set redirect URLs
for successful payments and cancel
payments if stripe is unable to redirect
the user at all it will throw an error
object so if we get an error we'll just
go ahead and show an alert message for
now and now we just need a UI element
for the user to trigger the checkout
process so we'll go down here to the
template and add a button that fires
this method when clicked and it's also
worth noting that when you're working
with a mountain stripe they're based on
a currencies lowest denomination so an
amount of 1999 would be $19.99 in u.s.
dollars so you'll probably want to
divide the amount by 100 when showing
that in your front-end UI and now we can
use this product component somewhere
else in the application so we'll go into
the app component and then declare the
product there then pass in the props
like the SKU and the amount that we want
to use for this product and now we can
run NPM run dev to serve the app locally
when you click the checkout button it
should redirect the user to the checkout
page with your specific product details
after a payment is submitted you'll be
able to see it on the stripe dashboard
it's from here that you can process
refunds see the risk evaluation download
invoices and all that good stuff
now at this point we've received a
payment from the customer but now we
need to do our part to fulfill the
product when the payment intent has
succeeded stripe will instantly send a
web hook to a URL that we specify the
URL can point to an HTTP cloud function
that will then handle the data for that
payment intent and then fulfill the
product for the user so to get started
on the backend we'll need to initialize
firebase cloud functions by running
firebase and net functions from the
command line and I'll be using
typescript in this project from there
we'll CD into the functions directory
and I'll be using Express Jas cores and
also the stripe SDK and then we'll also
want to install types for stripe and
cores this will give us intellisense for
the entire stripe API which is
incredibly useful when building a
payment system on the backend
now one minor thing we need to do for
typescript is go into the TS config and
use the es next Lib now in the index TS
file
we'll start by initializing stripe by
first importing it and then passing it
the secret API key from the stripe
dashboard you can see I've just
hard-coded it into the source code here
but it's generally a better idea to save
it as an environment variable in your
firebase project from there I'm going to
create an Express j/s app so we can
create multiple API endpoints with a
single cloud function this is
technically optional but if you have a
lot of different payment endpoints on
your back-end it generally helps to use
some sort of HTTP framework to help you
manage that complexity or in the full
stripe course we use something called
callable functions which integrate with
the firebase SDK on the front end to
simplify both the front-end and back-end
code but it's beyond the scope of this
video from there we'll create a post
endpoint for our web hook and inside
this hook the first thing we'll want to
do is validate that it actually came
from stripe and not from some random
hacker on the web we can do that by
looking for a stripe signature header
and then we can use a value called the
endpoint secret to decode the data that
was in that request or webhooks sent
from stripe the stripe SDK has a special
method called web hooks construct event
that takes the body of the request the
stripe signature and the endpoint secret
and combines them all together into some
JSON that we can actually use in our
code now the one thing we're missing is
the actual secret key for this web hook
head over to the stripe dashboard and
create a new web hook the URL should be
the actual location that you've deployed
your firebase function to which in our
case would be our main functions URL
followed by payments slash web hook then
for this demo the actual web hook that
you want to listen to is payment intent
dot succeeded and you can also look at
the payment intent payment failed as
well
now once you've created that web hook go
ahead and grab the secret code and then
paste it into your firebase project and
again that would be better as a firebase
environment variable from there we can
simply set up a switch statement to
handle the type of web hook that was
sent I'm going to leave the code
implementation details up to your
imagination here but you would most
likely update the firestore database or
send an email to a customer or something
along those lines it's entirely
dependent on the business logic of your
app and the product that you sell then
if the payment failed you may want to
send the customer an email saying you
have an open invoice and here is where
to pay it and you now have a full stack
payment solution with stripe no
jas and spelled nice but the main
drawback up striped checkout is that it
offers very few options to customize the
user experience so I want to finish off
this video by giving you a rundown of
how to use the payment intents API along
with stripe elements to not only handle
custom payments but also to handle the
3d secure authentication process if it's
necessary in the spell tap you can see
here that we enter some card details and
then if it needs to go through 3ds
secure stripe will automatically bring
up that 3d secure process in your apps
page so the user never really leaves
your app to finish their payment now
there's a lot more code involved in this
process and we're not going to go
through it line by line instead we'll
look at the implementation of five
different steps that you need to take to
handle payment intense with stripe
elements step one is to create a payment
intent on the back end when the user
signifies an intention to pay you money
when that happens you make a request to
your back-end for a payment intent
object which you can create with the
stripe SDK it takes an amount currency
and some additional optional parameters
as well in your front-end code you'll
need to make a request to this end point
in these felt app we'll handle that with
the on mount lifecycle hook although you
should only create one payment intent
per user session in our case we can
request the payment intent using the
browser fetch API and then take the
response and set it as the payment
intent property on the spelt component
that returns the payment intent from our
server which contains an important value
called the client secret once we have
the client secret we can then move on to
the third step which is collecting the
user's credit card information and
building the actual credit card form
striped elements provides pre-built
widgets that we can use to validate
credit card details on the front end all
we have to do is grab a Dom element with
spelt and then we'll mount the striped
card on that element from there we move
on to step number four which is to
process the payment and that happens
entirely on stripe server not your own
server you do that by calling handle
kart payment and it takes the client
secret that you returned from your own
server along with the card element where
the user entered their card details here
on the front end its return value is an
updated payment intent with any charges
that have been added to that intent so
it takes the payment intent you created
on your back-end the card details the
user entered on the front end and turns
that into an
actual charge that you can fulfill at
that point you can show the user a
confirmation in the UI and then you
should actually fulfill the purchase by
running a web hook just like we did with
the previous example so I'm gonna go
ahead and wrap things up there I hope
that gave you an idea of how to work
with stripe checkout and the payment
intense API and if you're serious about
integrating payments into your
progressive web app and consider
becoming a pro member at fire ship IO to
get access to the full course thanks for
watching and I will talk to you soon
oh I like money
[Music]